35 years ago the hiv
pandemic made international headlines
for the first time
since then 78 million people have become
infected with
hiv and 35 million have died from
aids-related illnesses world aids day is
an important reminder for
us all that hiv aids has not gone away
for the eu combating hiv aids remains a
priority
under horizon 2020 the commission is
continuing to support research
to develop novel or improved tools
against
hiv by april 2020 the commission
had already committed over 220 million
euros with the covet 19 pandemic
disproportionately affecting
vulnerable groups we must step up our
efforts
in raising awareness of the impact of
hiv
on people's lives and on leaving no one
behind
particularly those who are marginalized
or live in rural areas
we must act to end the widespread
discrimination and stigma
against people with or thought to have
hiv aids
the world aids day is a call for us to
renew our long-term
commitments and to commit to finding
innovative solutions
together we will build a culture of
solidarity
trust and perseverance